so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]
what is it msra Mr msra oh my God we
can't get an intro let's Let It Go let's
Let It Go let's start hey what's up guys
Thomas doubles whatever you want to call
me welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast this is my co-host Marty O'Neal
hey yo hey yeah
so we're trying to Star as the second
intro we're trying to start it's ASMR
as Mister remember yeah yeah not a and g
or AARP whatever this is yo what's up
guys uh welcome back sorry sorry for
this intro welcome back guys today's our
guest is OG all right
hi new glasses
of course really those are way Square on
the top they almost look like these
Chanel ones I saw that's why I noticed
it right off the bat don't be lined fool
sent me to cholo land the other day oh
yeah
for the Ted Talk clothes I'm like yo I
need a yo I called him like I need a Pro
Club shirt and he went oh nice finally
died
that's not a story full give me an
address it's by Target which one you
know controller land
you're lucky you didn't wear that shirt
last night I almost did I almost did hey
man thanks for coming back on the show
on such short notice yeah and he's sober
now guys he doesn't drink a drop of
liquor at all until he picks up his cup
again it will not be sober anymore this
was drunk all right he didn't drive you
you're gonna get [__] faced today uh no
actually I did drive here it's diluted
so he can't
right yo oh that's the first question I
want to start with
what did we talk about last night
during the Ted Talk oh a TED Talk
so while you're talking about how
successful that's not it you were you
are
no let's see I don't know um you know
what tight truth is what I'm going to
tell you I think they lowered the mic on
you guys bro because everybody else was
so [__] loud and when it came to you
guys I was like what the [__] like if
they just turned it down a little Notch
bro really did you honestly did you see
I couldn't hear the speakers towards you
guys well yeah because I I recorded
other people when they were talking and
then [__] [__] was loud and then you
guys came up and it was like kind of low
I was like what the [__] it's a good
excuse you guys at the end too I was
just like [__] bro I was kind of like I
think everybody was pissed off yeah and
it is good it is it did it was a good
show yep for sure yeah that's what we
were talking about well we will talk
about how he used to hustle before and
how he you know went legit he didn't
want to hustle no more and you know oh
he listened yeah me and Marty let's
let's have him break down what we talked
about yeah I know for sure and then
Mario came out of the host after I know
right what the [__] everybody was pissed
because he's like because that's a whole
but he's gonna call you out and he
caught someone else I was like that's
[__] disrespectful for okay
all right we'll wait for you guys
nothing wrong it's just it just kept
kept getting pushed back and that's all
yeah yeah that sure was cool though yeah
I found out moments before the host had
to dip out so they're like hey can you
you got 10 seconds it was a little late
the host had to leave us at a certain
time that he was done well Dan the
[__] was talking like
[__] a whole hour in between
each other and I was like damn bro is
this the I want like is this a TED talk
or is he just you know what's a I missed
the whole thing I was in the back of
studying my notes and then and then I
forgot that was pretty much it
it's pretty all right all right cool
cool can we hit this pool with where you
at right off the bat yeah can we do that
real quick you got it right can you run
it yeah yeah yeah this is the second
let's call where you at
and Marty's gonna ask you two things and
that's it you say where are you at with
it that's it where am I how do I feel a
second did we already do the uh the 16
year old version with OG oh let's do
that first oh gee I have a question I
ask people I like to ask certain guests
this question I don't think I asked you
yeah if 16 year old you walks in the
door
are you gonna beat the dog [__] out of
him or he's gonna [__] you up
a 16 year old me walked in the docks in
the door and you guys gotta fight are
you gonna win
or do you lose do you know what after
that cup 16 year old me I would probably
no guns involved
you know no that's a that was a little
Loose Cannon dude probably I probably uh
no probably wouldn't be able to the old
man strong doesn't outweigh that though
oh well actually yeah but you know back
then I mean I don't know it was a little
more different a little more aggressive
did you ever have a stretch where you
were like lifting in chat working out
heavy uh you know what um nah not too
much if I if I do work out and [__] like
say it in a year if I do work out I'm
gonna work out maybe twice maybe two
months
out of the whole the whole year maybe
you don't hear that a lot yeah you know
every [__] I don't [__] oh we got 60
days a year I mean [__] you know that's
realistic I mean it's the truth I mean
[__] I work like about maybe some days
12 hours a day you'd be doing those 10
hours a day 12 hours 13 hours so you
know what I mean so so you're going
there at nine and you're in there until
[__] nine yeah damn for sure I mean
don't get me wrong I didn't you know
I'll do push-ups in my office that's
what he told me I just hit 100 push-ups
like yeah right full yeah no in in a
whole day in my work maybe I could bust
about maybe 250 push-ups yeah for sure
that's a lot is this funny I mean
staring at the camera
you know what this fool does instead of
politely
intercoming hey
um Melissa can you come in the back he
does this
smacks his wall until somebody hears him
on the other side and then they show him
and that big ass building that's allowed
to [__] with music No usually I Buzz the
door no besides that I've seen you just
do this I'm calling him but yeah so that
girl with the tattoo shows up
he answered the phone this morning he
goes all right no call her in call her
in I want to fire her
when I can answer the phone today I
don't know what it is about some weed
shops but they just constantly go
through you know what it is
New Generation bro if there's something
else bro I mean you heard the tattoo
they seemed like I mean work is like you
got a joke it's something else to them
you know what I mean
it's not the same yeah I mean thank you
thank you you would think people would
be motivated to be you know happy to get
more hours to work and it's like nah
they're just the last hours if you send
them home they're like happy it's not
like [__] you know what I mean like
really I want to say I want to work now
they're gone how many people with good
work ethics have come through that
you're like damn this [__] is a
beast
uh well it depends because you know I
have three different departments you
know I have a trim Department uh there's
a growth department and then I have my
retail so I mean uh yeah sometimes I do
I get good I get a lot of good uh
trimmers that are you know pretty good
I'll stick around a long time got good
worth got work ethics well yeah I trip
out so I'm like oh [__] you know where'd
this guy come from you know I mean she's
pretty fast well you've been on well you
know what I mean um same thing you know
I have a few bartenders that are you
know they commit and [__] but for the
foremost no how many people are getting
canned a quarter
20. oh oh [__] no I'm constantly we're
always firing people dude I mean [__] I
mean like I said people want to just
come in do what they want to do and
they're just like man it's like it's
different now people got like this
attitude and [__] like you know like
[__] bro it's like everything's changing
now like you work for them yeah yeah
exactly you know what I mean like I just
hired a guy I mean just what this week
and uh they told me on YouTube oh no I
don't want to do that because I'm not
going to be here that long I go dude you
just got hired it's your first day what
do you mean you don't want to [__] do
that you're not gonna be here that long
[__] you're [__] right so now the
next day you're gone bro you ain't gonna
be here the second day you know so I
when I caught one of them like nah you
don't even come to second day get them
out of here who had the button was it
Monty Burns
it drops him in your office in the next
level remember on Simpsons Mr Burns they
bring people in the office he goes
you're fired and you hit the button
they'd fall into the budget you need one
I wish I had one of those slide and it
shoots him to the front door
that would be great for sure that would
be good hey you ever seen this movie
Babes in Toyland
we Keanu Reeves no no what is it Babes
in Toyland no what the [__] what did
that come out [__] like 1984 apparently
oh [__]
wanted to come out
83. I'm out there you know the year I'm
like okay what year was she born
a little after that
all right so anyway there's one of those
little dungeons I saw that joint that
she almost hit you in the face
that's your last night tangerines yeah
whatever you rolled all the time the
Tangy he brought we don't know his runts
yeah that [__] smoked good dude I was
actually shocked when I took off I had
one joint left of the same one that I
gave him and I'm smoking I'm just like
what the [__] am I looking like what did
I do and I'll even looked at like what
is it yeah yeah I was doing the same
thing and then I mean
what is that did I write a little
initials on that she goes no and I go
well damn and I guess that's the [__]
runs you know what I mean that [__] was
[__] fire dude I wasn't small I
didn't take dabs the whole week before
this Ted talk last night guys for
everybody out there guys last night we
did the Ted talk right excuse me [__]
yeah air horn there you go air horns you
don't hear them if you had those
headphones you did not I did thank you
everybody that came out to Ted Talk it
was [__] to me thank you and if we
saw you before we went on
I'm sorry I was uh I said hi to
everybody but I felt like I couldn't get
in full conversation
annoying people oh please
I was in the corner just pacing talking
to myself looking like we weren't
backstage
back and forth and yeah I was trying to
remember my speed he kept bumping into
fans and they'd be like
like not expecting to come around the
corner and see him and they were just
like it would happen a couple times
people had to catch their [__] breath
that kid was fainted yeah dude what
about that building though the garden
was something else
statues on the wall I'd even want to see
your little faces
lighter that's some [__] that's these
the old theaters in Hollywood got some
Vibes
you go to the bathroom yeah it's like a
New York Subway down there I did not Jay
you go to the bathroom uh uh
there was theater seats in there
so someone does like a single person
play yeah you know dude the the the dude
that was with the light and [__] yeah
that man lives there
right yeah he lives there bro he got his
own spot in there everything oh geez oh
she's making it up actually no it's
right here he has a tail it's gone
check it out he walked out he walked out
and came back like with a regular type
of cup like a house cup and I was like
where'd this fool go so he went up to
the top and came back like with a house
cup so I was like oh [__] there's
apartments above it though well oh
really oh okay well that I did not know
but I did see him come back with a house
cup and then I did see him come like if
he was coming like if you look at his
Pad you know what I mean yeah
this [__] lives here or what I
mean it looked like it did because I
mean [__] like Last Action Hero uh like
that old man that just stays at the
theater all day more like the die hard
to do this in the airport or in the
[__] you know like Brad Pitt and
Fight Club you know you know they'll do
that [__] the janitor that lives
there actually he has a little spot and
he lives inside yeah you ready I've only
seen die hard one
[__] I know I have movie full I've never
watched it I think I started Force after
the fourth after the fourth or third
again I've seen first and fourth only I
think the last song with Samuel Jackson
That's the last one that's probably the
best that's it I don't remember hey
ready we never asked this fool what's
your favorite top three movies ever
yeah
did you guys feel that [__] no we can
hear it
sounds horrible fools are driving doing
this right now what is that called am Mr
they like that [__] people like that
[__] what's this trademark [__] they
must have said oh that [__] felt
relaxing damn what you doing homie see
if you had your [__] you would hear it
deep in your in your head what's your
top three favorite movies
uh well the real don't say something
stupid I mean I like Casino [__] you
know I like the old school movies um one
I like [__] from the 80s I want to
say [__] uh Bad Boys with Sean Penn
Sean Penn and uh uh what's his face La
Bamba's brother
uh Lou Diamond Phillips brother yeah
yeah Ralph what's his full name
what
is Morales damn Bros
that's a good movie actually when we're
done I have hella sodas to beat you with
yeah
bro you know
um
[__] there's a lot of them there's not
just three my three top movies because
[__] I really don't have three top
movies I got like [__] every time you
talk about movies what are your favorite
movies go [__] ah [__] let's see
um
Casino [__] heat [__] uh [__] yeah
ladies [__] you know what I mean uh I
like you're saying Cape Fear yeah that's
a pretty good one he could do pull-ups I
can't do pull-ups yeah that's a good one
you know a series you know [__] uh
Sopranos and [__] like that Breaking Bad
I still [__] watch Breaking Bad here
and there I go back to certain episodes
that's worth it it's a good show yeah
[__] you especially yeah you're like oh
[__] when you're high as [__] you've
been like oh [__]
that was one of the main shows that I
was just like couldn't believe every
time they kept going it kept getting
better
right this [__] was a nut and
like there's nobody that's ever
transformed that much within a show I
feel like from like Dad to [__]
psychopath and like why you gotta think
about it the dude's about to exit live
so I mean [__] I mean if you ain't think
about it [__]
I mean what I mean if you know you're
about to die and you're gonna die so you
have so much time I mean [__] who best
thing to do is [__] take care of the
[__] that you want [__] that
you didn't like
unless you to say the people around you
take care of your family
that was a big twist hey actually hold
on
ethos
E1 no one one shark you're gonna give me
[__] crossfaded with this one shark
those are the placebos yeah he got no he
was in no stop let me tell the story
stop let me set the scene nah this fool
is not is this fool has a home multiple
cars a backyard a front yard a garage a
couch a dad a dad I call him what are
you doing on my lawn I'm like all right
cool in your in your car yeah
bottle of wine
well Chuck and wine Hot Box in his car
and just on his in his front yard two in
the morning I'm like all right that's
cool then he pulls up the whole bottle
of wine where's Mindy's here laugh and
then that joint comes back into the face
time then he goes all right I'll try to
put you little shots they're not gonna
do nothing he chucked two of them
we're on the phone for 30 minutes and
this full started I don't know I never
had some [__] like that before in my
life that's pretty much what he was
doing and then the next morning we're
supposed to go on a drive and I go
you're not calling me you're not calling
me by one I'll give you till three
you're not calling me you called me at
five o'clock no I actually I had to wake
up the next morning and take my daughter
to work and it was like yeah and then
you said I came home
Thanksgiving holidays right Thanksgiving
and uh so [__] bro I had to wake up the
next day and like so I'm talking to him
like at two in the morning maybe one
Thirty what yeah and I checked those two
things all of a sudden I get waking up
with my daughter at like seven in the
morning 6 30 in the morning or something
like that like you need to take me to
work come on let's go and I'm just bro I
get up and I'm like [__] bro I'm
literally driving and I'm like I feel
dizzy almost I'm thinking to myself
because I forget I forgot that I had to
finish two shirts or something I go no
you drink two two shots two full syrups
all right yeah two full syrups you know
what I mean so I'm thinking to myself
while I'm driving you know I'm thinking
like [__] man you know what I need to go
to I need to go to the doctor and get
checked bro I go this is not normal bro
I feel like your brain
I'm like I'm not here or what bro I go
there's something wrong with me you
forgot you can't drop her off I go back
to the bed and now I can't sleep now I'm
like [__] so I'm hungover and I'm like
you know what [__] this
I go to the store and grab me a beer
like bro two minutes from
that work
I mean well it got me more like more
[__] weirdness
like mom drunk yeah you're hot and drunk
yeah oh yeah now I'm high and I'm drunk
again because you know I'm like [__] you
know the alcohol kicks in now you know
and I only have [__] no don't get it
wrong no it was just one beer but like
maybe already like I'm already like at
my six-pack and I call this film like
hey man what the [__] next thing like I
still feel [__] high I go that's when
I remember like oh this is what I did
because I think you know when I was in
my car I think I I looked at my my
daughter's all like oh what's this you
know they're all empty a little oh [__]
and I'm like oh [__] oh now I don't know
what the [__] come on I'm over here
thinking I gotta go to the doctor for
Monday morning did it hit was it a
delayed hit like oh no hell no bro I
mean I was on the phone with him I was
crashing in the walls like you know when
I was when I oh [__] I'm gonna take you
to work I'm only hitting oh yeah and I'm
like [__] you know you didn't get to
really sleep it off is the problem uh oh
Hammer you can't I don't think you can
sleep I don't think you can man because
dude when I did the challenge I need
three oh yeah and I woke up when I woke
up I called our partner Claudia and goes
yo we gotta retest everything we gotta
redo everything I don't feel as good I
feel I don't feel safe I'm so [__] up
we got to retest Thomas
you think we didn't do all this before
we even [__] package I'm like yeah I
know we did but can we read text like
dude it's the hacp and I go oh yeah
they're hacp inside it's 30 times
stronger than our normal edible three is
a lot it's [__] three it's 90 times I
drink two all the door is just after
that second one the syrups are another
it's actually what uh 72 hours bro I
mean I believe that's what takes a while
to get away get it out of your system
yeah I mean
[__] I took some artists so not that
long ago about maybe two three weeks ago
and you know I gave some to a couple
co-workers too everybody's like what the
[__] did you give me all right
everybody's like I feel weird and you
know the next day because I go well yeah
you know it's to me the the dose that I
give you is going to be a 72 73 or 74
hour High bro it's gonna be three days
what is it do you eat it all right so
but I'm saying like it's actually you
need it you get hash oil okay it's
disgusting I'm saying you in this
instance you ate it yeah yeah for sure
you know I mean I've made it and I made
it with like you're supposed to make it
just with all the plant matter and [__]
but I made it with actual nugs you know
what I mean so this [__] this [__]
potent we're like I've taken some and um
I literally [__] my legs been numb
like I can't even get out the car I
literally have to pick my leg up
um pick my other leg up and go from Wall
Street yeah yeah I'm the RSO story where
he said take a little bit fill it up I
didn't even fill it up and then I got
the spins I threw up everywhere I was
high I woke up the next day spanning
still high yeah it is
I think that [__] literally fixes you
bro
hey yeah if you want a research ours so
you go on Google research yourself We're
not gonna be pushing that you know RSO
sales people because we might get our
whole [__] existence onto YouTube
just deleted for that yeah you are I
mean it's all over man yeah I know just
go look Google RSO Rick Simpson Oil
coincidentally anymore and I made it
afterwards coincidentally I felt better
yeah you felt better it always does it
like it resets you it resets your body
like a mushroom trip you know what I
mean right now whenever you you [__]
your little off and [__] your [__]
balance is a little off I guarantee you
take half of the syringes tomorrow so
half a gram and four days later after
you come back yeah you'll be all right
yeah three days later you know
reset you and you're gonna feel good
about yourself like you just feel good
everything even it's like [__] it
like it I'm gonna say this right now I
gave this one girl some and um
it was actually uh it was actually what
actually you know what it was my cousin
and my and my and my other and my other
brother you know rest in peace I gave
him some and they both came at me with
the both the same you know hey you know
what
when I couldn't sleep I was having like
these crazy like [__] like like
nightmares that were like evil like bad
[__] like you know like like something
bad and I'm like what the [__] so my my
brother first told me he's like yeah I
was on the couch and I was like having
like some weird scary [__] where like
I've never felt that I was oh trip out
and then all of a sudden and I was like
oh trip
I mean I felt that [__] myself too yeah
myself but I mean my thing is that I I
thought it was just me you know [__]
okay my [__] going on in my head [__]
that's probably what happens cool not
the my other mother
um another homegirl came too and she's
just like nah man that [__] [__] like
took the demons out of me and I was like
what the [__] like wait a minute that's
that's [__] crazy because you know my
[__] my you know my brother Snuffy
just told me the same thing too you
heard me he told me like some [__]
like evil [__] was like coming in and
out of him and I was like oh [__] you
know then I think I think honestly it it
really works like that wherever this
[__] [__] comes from because I mean
it's like a mushroom trip yeah well it
goes to into your brain and kind of
deals with the [__] that's in your head
also will get you so [__] up your
body's probably like they deal with the
[__] in your head because your body's
not gonna do anything right now you
better work on your head to work on your
[__] body you know what I mean
because mushrooms do the same [__] for
sure yeah must we do the same exact
thing it's just like an internal
cleansing I would say so get the [__]
shark is what I'm trying to say eat a
shark man this book is trying to get one
shark it's 100 milligrams nah 100
milligrams yes 100 milligrams weighted
yeah I know it's 100 okay so let's say
this so 100 milligrams how many
milligrams in it would be if it were to
be THC just uh more or less what would
you think 70. oh [__] that 70 milligrams
70 as well I think 70 milligrams almost
on a daily use
take a bite of it one bite you want me
to taste it yeah they're brand new look
yeah no bro I've seen what this [__]
does to you bro I know take a bite I
just want you there's a new one a sour
watermelon oh bro I didn't even tell you
remember those [__] ones those um
those gummies we got in Vegas the hash
gummies no the mushroom gummies did it
hit you oh bro I [__] forgot that
they were [__] and you ate them I I
know I you know because I wasn't gonna
eat the whole thing because you know I'm
like [__] it I ate half of it
and [__] bro I'm [__] like I'm going
to work and [__] and I'm just like what
the [__] did I just see the [__] the
light like and I'm like she forgot you
ate mushroom gummies
like I said once again man [__] I need
to go to the [__] Hospital
something's wrong with me you keep a
diary of the same [__] bro
this episode's called [__] I didn't
[__] go to the doctor dude seriously
something's wrong with me I thought it
was something wrong with me again you
know I'm thinking well what did I eat
like oh I ate that edible and I think
you know wait a minute that [__]
edible was [__] they were mushrooms
they weren't [__] and I'm like oh
[__] bro my mom ate the whole entire box
and she said she felt nothing oh really
I gave her that one too and then I gave
her a bunch of other [__] that they gave
me really she said they did nothing to
her I got a whole bag of the the legal
mushrooms at my house to try because we
want to do the dopest mushrooms the
dopest rooms okay the legal mushrooms
and ship all 50 say it's [__] great
but if they don't hit you I ain't
[__] no no yeah yeah my mom's like
these ones didn't work but you're like
damn Lucy Tracy oh no no no it didn't
hit like a normal mushroom I'll tell you
that right now it did it that's right
yeah it was more like I just kept seeing
like little [__] streaks and I'm over
here thinking about [__] man [__] I
hear about this [__] people saying they
see little [__] lies something's
wrong with them so I'm like well
something's wrong with me too though but
then I realized what I did [__] about
took me about an hour to finally this
was freaking out for an hour then he
goes oh yeah I ate mushrooms at the same
time I'm over here thinking I need to be
that Carefree with my life dude that I
ate mushrooms and just go to work
the doctor's like bro we gotta we gotta
work something out you can't be calling
me like this
did you eat anything today
yeah sorry doctor oh no [__] no yeah
yeah no you don't want to try one you
don't want to go to your doctor it
tastes like uh I think they taste like
red Kool-Aid
it's only 100 milligrams bro come on oh
he went with you you could walk that bag
down look out of here are you doing with
me I do are you two right now
why are you three I'm looking forward to
this video
The Challenge is good yeah does
Tuesday's just throw half of the shark
back in the Box
yeah so let's get back out of the
conversation
no by the way by the way you should take
one more bite do one more bite no it
might be a little bit more volume
take a bite at my ass the [__] you say
sometimes also those are hacp and THC
yeah you see little jerk
so the new double shop [__] they're
Delta 9 THC and hhcp and hhc
those ones are dead well now he's got to
try the gems
it's only right [__] um here you go
I do the same [__] no I don't know
the smaller this [__] is the more
[__] dangerous this [__] is
[Laughter]
[__] out of here come on it's like the
minute black guys
you know how many people I get and I
[__] I get a lot of people I get a lot
of people to eat [__] am I working
[__]
I [__] give everybody bricks a lot of
people no I know what he's saying
they're two milligrams bro they're
samples
a few months ago we got some cookies
from the [__] some some company you
know cookies and [__] so I got them and
I [__] seen these other bags you know
what I took them out of the [__] out
of the packaging put them on some like
casual packaging [__] one in the back
I'm like oh you know right now Avengers
brought me these cookies you guys
wanting what [__] yeah I'll take one
these don't have no no [__] THC or
you do that I'm like nah not at all
right now bro got him
you're this work environment he's
tripping out on mushrooms [__] no what
is this little [__] Cherry Bomb take
him apart it's one it's two times I
thought it was two I thought no like
some type of strawberries get together
no they're uh hell no fool [__] Bro
they're CBD and they cheats CBD the CBD
and HH he ate it
it is two gems and it tastes real good
they're [__] those are the children's
ones right yeah those are the melatonin
and CBD ones you want me to put me to
sleep oh yeah that's right huh
[__] end of the podcast I'm [__]
right here we'll draw on you don't worry
I'll do a laugh
all right these are good they are good
how are you taking bites you're taking
you just Squidward
he did
I'm [__] testing them no take they're
good they're actually really good right
at least they're 15 milligrams
15 milligrams are you kidding me let me
[__] read this dude he doesn't have
his reading glasses on there trust me
he goes out the red looks
and then 20th they don't [__] say how
strong they are right yes they do
they're 15 it says one five per serving
yeah well eat one if you don't eat food
I could taste that [__] 15 milligrams yo
your name is OG not hoji or noji 15
milligrams
all right one really really really
really [__] 103 [__] up me home
what's the peer pressure I love it keep
it back oh you're pretty pressuring them
this man just talked about [__]
dosing people don't get mad at me you
ate one yeah let me see go on your
tongue I know I'm just kidding lift your
tongue hey hey how are you dude
my whole bag just too I don't want to
[__] up the show bro are you ready those
are Hash House Edibles yeah I know yeah
those are don't tell me I already know
those are 50 milligrams
you're done those are strong I can't
wait
he's talking about tricking people oh
no it's all good [__] [__] man it's all
good [__] [__] so much [__] [__] I've
eaten mushrooms [__] me I'm good they
need the other one nah I'm not trying to
get all I want to get all hashed out
because you know tomorrow I don't want
to [__] [__] my day off in the
morning Sunday you're doing [__] and the
Raiders lost today yeah what the [__] do
you care hold on real quick how can the
rate hold on here we go
everybody go watch the microphone
touchdown oh my God oh my God
that was probably the stupidest [__] I
ever done on the [__] show in my life
you saw it I saw the captain and said
that the Chiefs are toying with their
food what'd you do I looked around the
warehouse right now
because I was going to go like this I
was looking for a microphone something
that could be used as a microphone I
moved my microwave
that I could go this way we're talking
to this I could have just oh my [__]
that's like me lighting it yeah
it's like looking for your phone while
you're on your phone yeah yeah you're
using your flashlight yeah I'm gonna
have my phone I'm like looking for my
phone and I'm like where's my [__]
phone yo I don't know if my brain my
brain is not back yet people don't
understand we need to address the amount
of brain power it takes to write a
[__] Ted Talk and memorize it
bro oh my God I felt like I was back at
school dude it was like okay it was
looking such a
I still did that ready yeah it's like we
ran a [__] Marathon like that that's
how I exhausted yeah my brain feels like
slow and laggy like I couldn't do a
story time I feel right he basically
wrote I memorized a short book that's
exactly what we did
he wrote memorized in a 20-minute
audiobook yeah yeah so uh by the way
microphone fake microphone how can the
Raiders come back next year and be one
of the top teams in the NFL what do you
think they are lacking what do you think
their qualities are and what do you
think needs to be changed
what it is bro [__] it is what it is bro
[__] that's why the Raiders are [__]
losing in the first place man that's
what the Raiders teammates are saying it
is what it is if I sit here and I say uh
we need a new [__] coach we need how
many [__] coaches that we [__] ran
through how many of you [__]
quarterbacks how many full [__] it is
what it is you know I mean it's still my
[__] team [__] it you know what I
mean man listen I [__] appreciate
what you're saying yeah you know what I
mean sometimes you go through 30 years
ago yeah exactly bro yeah who hasn't got
through some [__] like that bro ain't
nothing [__] you bro you know what I
mean so I mean you got a cool Stadium
Tom Brady yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's get ready to rumble or uh USC this
time it's
it's time yeah yeah you're at home you
got him every right oh have you been to
the radio game in in Vegas no bro Bruce
Buffer comes out and announces the whole
[__] steam really every player as
they come out oh wow get ready and he's
standing up and they have a spotlight on
him and he's a live band playing and for
the [__] out of here I've never seen
that [__] I went to the game America
told you what you did cool remember I
went with Rosie in her birthday oh [__]
dude I went to the stadium all right
they have Bruce Buffer on a spotlight
as they come in and they have a live
band playing and they bring a band in
during halftime and they play up top and
you can see everybody looks like it's
oh [__] all right no I didn't even know
anyway that's Bruce Buffer I got a fight
with Bruce and UFC for
stopping yeah stop it it's just
grappling I didn't pick him up
he's not a fighter that's crazy as hell
all right you ready let's get back on
topic yeah let's go all about the
Raiders or something yeah and I was just
talking [__] I know who cares there's
nothing you're gonna say that the
analyst didn't say already you know I
mean well what they need to do is like
Al Davis what they need to do is [__]
you know what I mean take it away now
Davidson needs a new [__] haircut I
know I know I'm sorry Al Davis but your
hair his haircut his [__] haircut can
you can you bring up Al Davis Jr
haircut just put
he looks like the top Jim Carrey uh
Lloyd Christmas and the bottom he look I
don't understand look at his hair he
looks like who they based one of the
[__] dumb and dumber off of look at
his no look at the [__] oh my God
I'm sorry guys that's where's the comedy
I don't know that shit's fake correct
that's the book can be fake and hold on
before we keep coming this guy like
[__] 100 of those let me keep saying
it I'm sorry that we're sitting here
making fun of someone's looks that's
something we shouldn't be doing at all
ever but that's a very very funny
haircut and we had to talk [__] change
your hair you're a billionaire
come on man I'm sorry but
there he is right
that's right better all right that's it
that's just that's a good haircut that
fits him look out of here that on the
right that looks like a regular looks
like yeah the [__] chili but look at
the other ones the other ones makes him
look like what they call them skin
crawlers Skin Walkers that's what you
look like in that white picture he
looked like a creature the girl has the
same type of haircut like that
if you have blue glowy eyes yeah he
looks like a monster of some kind I'm so
sorry
change it to something else Melissa
don't be talking about our leader like
that man yo is Derek Carr out you know
what I think so [__] I think he is alive
I haven't watched football in so long
[__] um
burning his jersey yeah I mean [__] bro
you can't it's organization sell it sell
it yeah sell it and buy a jersey yeah
I'll tell you this right now dude's
gonna do better wherever else he goes
I'll tell you that he's gonna break
records
that's what it always happens yeah did
you feel like Skip Bayless was justified
in taking all the heat that he took this
week I don't know if you know about that
around the Demar Hamlin situation his
tweet OG definitely does not oh no [__]
get baylesses yeah
they hit the [__] no that just went
in yeah that is not Skip Bayless he's in
he's a he's a correspondent guy oh so he
said something stupid thing what you're
saying yeah if he showed him a picture
you go oh
man I didn't hear about it you know what
I don't really I don't know I see here
anyway he was he was just he said some
[__] when that kid had a heart attack on
the field he said something like yo this
game is important they need to figure it
out and everybody's like yo you're
insensitive and that's it but before
that he's a [__] dick anyway yeah you
guys never been like hey you know what I
like him I like him Shannon sharp on the
other hand yeah it's different you know
why because he's a [__] NFL legend
yeah and a giant horse of a man he's as
big as a horse and he's probably as fast
yeah Shannon Sharps is a 60 year old
his back is like a ninja turtle oh yeah
you filmed with him yeah [__] huge
still he showed me a picture you're
[__] because it's able this is what
his back is like he was like I've done
the same thing every day for the past 20
years you say he's the same breakfast
yeah exact [__] what do you drive like a
2 000 escalators like I bought this and
I I needed another car he's like I don't
go anywhere it doesn't have any miles to
do the same [__] every day yeah wake up
and do this what the [__] yeah dude that
was a different mind he's like
you got to watch the David Goggins dude
yeah he showed me David Goggins a long
time ago but recently started watching
some of his [__] you should watch this
Fool's insane it's full friends yeah
Ultra marathons what they were called
yeah Ultra marathons 246 mile marathon
runs yeah like across the state straight
what from here to [__] straight
but he's like
no that's that's fine
yeah oh she's an endurance athlete Navy
SEAL dude bro I was watching some [__]
the Navy SEAL yeah yeah oh yeah oh he
went on Rogan that's how he got famous
really but he has a book and Marty just
listened to his second book
I just watched some of his interviews
and the [__] he's talking about his knee
yeah was unbelie he reconstructed his
entire knee he's running on a broken leg
just running every day and he had two
holes in his heart he set the Guinness
World Record for pull-ups he had dead
like multiple ultra marathon 100 mile
marathon how many posts I don't know
that off the top of my head uh I forget
he said it [__] yeah they had to go
in he had to do two heart surgeries so
since his first book he took two heart
surgeries oh [__] and then um so with
the same heart though yeah they just
they put a mesh on it and the heart
heals around the mesh and they said it
was the size of like a [__] coin oh
and he was doing seals however right no
it wasn't your heart the beat is off I
think oh it's not when you have a hole
in your heart you know what you know
what I think you might be right actually
you let us know oh we have the power of
the internet yeah uh yeah because we
might be wrong you guys both might be
right I'm just just how can but that's
like it has to do with uh that's what
it's called I have one more joint you
want to roll more joints are you good
yeah the Demar Hamilton too because they
said that it happened because of the
specific moment he got hit within his
heartbeat like if it would have happened
at a different point in the heartbeat
his heart wouldn't have stopped so it
was like The Kill Bill [__] two inch
punch hit so you think maybe that's what
happened to homeboy that got hit that's
what they said that's what why he he
died on the field yeah yeah they brought
him back to life on the field and at the
hospital that's so scary dude so it's
like all the other NFL players now if I
were NFL player every time I got hit
okay now I know I mean you can't be
scared bro I don't even care about time
to go yeah man if it's not your time
it's not your time well that dude like
honestly I I I play football my whole
life
watch football whole life
so there's a lot of people that is the
first time it's ever ever happened
that's crazy
that it happened again
or something like that that was uh
yeah I don't know but I think you get
smacked in the chest that shows
that were getting [__] hit in the
chest ten a lot about five times more
harder than that what he got bro he
barely got hit what he talking about
it's just angle I'm saying we've seen
people get yeah I think maybe I think
maybe homeboys album might have went
into something right he might have
something that we didn't see or maybe he
like dipped underneath with his shoulder
blade and just popped himself it doesn't
take that much I mean like even his
adrenaline maybe that he even let out
too that's another thing bro I mean [__]
yeah there's a lot of yeah a lot of
things I saw a diagram my baseball could
do it the ball could do it I mean if it
hits you in the right I mean [__] it's
going oh yeah bro you get hit in the
chest and you [__] bro I mean
cause I'm thinking of all the times I've
gotten smacked
that's not an option to to what you stop
my arm we've been hit Me Harder hit me
harder than because it's not going to
happen that's how I feel like that's
such a freak accident you'd even smoke
it's like when Randy Johnson had to hit
the bird with the baseball that was
crazy bro yeah you remember that other
one I had the butterfly with the Drone
bro I forgot
adventure oh just money still piece of
[__]
yeah anyway the guy that owes us money
we did a deal with at the very beginning
for a studio a stereo contract we've got
the butterfly story yeah we got a
butterfly story out of it and we it
doesn't matter I just [__] that guy
um
what the [__] oh that camera you
remember Randy Johnson the uh pitcher
when he threw the ball and the bird went
and it oh yeah popped the bird yep the
[__] pigeon yeah that [__]
that fool's the NFL photographer now no
[__] yeah look it up Randy Jones what
does Randy Johnson do now NFL
photographer bird photographer
crazy right watch he's a bird
photographer watch I saw him taking
pictures
look at Randy Johnson fell down he's out
there with the longest lens he's the guy
in this field in the NFL now oh that's
sick I love that
like that's pretty funny
he has nightmares that's crazy okay
let's get back under our [__] that was a
long time ago this is a segment called
where you at
Marty's going to ask you a series of
things and you say where are you at
meaning how do you feel about the topic
you can move that a lot closer to you
that was such a stretching yeah I know I
was thinking about those like [__] why
is this
do it you are good all right ready Marty
all right go for it where you at the
germs five second rule public door
handles things like that
bro we're [__] that's how we're made
we're made from germs and [__] oh okay I
don't give a [__] I don't I don't wash
my hands what [__] it no bro I mean I'm
not saying I'm not that guy's gonna go
wash my hands for every little [__]
thing I don't know that's a different
way yeah this is how I think this is how
we're created I think this is how we
live longer you know just like [__]
roaches same [__] you know I mean when
you put us all in the stadium
you put all these people everybody's
[__] breathing and we're thinking oh
yeah we're just [__] we're all right
here together [__] everybody's
[__] you know basically you CLG in
the street sneezing his face because he
don't give a [__]
worried about it I mean honestly no I
don't because you know what the more
germs you get the more healthy the more
stronger your immune system is going to
get the first person to have this view
so you know what I mean no hand
sanitizer you're not thinking about it
no who else did Dwight Schrute from the
office and that was a joke
so you're at the theater last night you
go down to the basement to the bathroom
the door is closed you're just yeah okay
bro
I'll tell you this stuff
no no for like three months what do they
say I ain't smoking with you and I would
put the joint right here and do this
swear to God
and was like did I ever get sick yes you
were gone for two weeks because you got
[__] sickness when the cover
came back I got sick all right there so
to me hey bro to me it's better for me
[__]
that's a [__] flu bro okay standards
okay
yeah I remember grind my feet
when everybody was literally [__]
scared and [__] I was still working and
I was I would have to do the whole drop
and count all the money which all the
money that's coming from out there oh
God and you know what there was there
was moments where I'll be kind of moment
that the about the money and I'll be
like you know I would [__] touch my
face thank you [__] follow me yeah I
ain't [__] you're not wearing glasses
[Laughter]
I'm just saying Bro [__] off so
basically OG doesn't use handstand does
he doesn't have a gigantic bottle on his
desk that he uses it every time he
touches money because he doesn't believe
in germs actually I want to use hand
sanitizer now like when I [__] touch
onions or some [__] I mean a [__]
taco or some [__] in on my mind keeping
the hand sanitizer already keep talking
or something because you know your
[__] ass smell like onion and [__]
but other than that like [__] you
know I'll go wash my hands that's the
only reason why I'll go wash my hands
for you know I can't stand I'm like bro
what the [__] is that the reason I said
it because you have a gigantic bottle of
hand sanitizer you use while you do the
count that I've seen uh no I ignore you
see okay
that's just there because it's there I
don't [__] be used like I said the
only time I use it if it's [__] like
I'll be honest with you sometimes I've
gotten money and I'm like what the [__]
this [__] has blood on it then that's
where I'm like [__] no I don't play that
[__] you know what I mean I want if I
see blood on a bill something then I
[__] go get the hand sanitizer all
[__] masks you know that's one thing
but oh my god
oh [__] what we got here nice oh [__] do
[__] new [__] so basically where you
have raw doggy door handles he'll suck
on them he'll [__] he don't give a [__]
bro
[__] yeah I will
let's do it I respect it he stands by it
too he's not [__] yesterday when he
walked to the duty
yeah open the door of his mouth I
watched him do it bro I mean I don't
know that's the way the more you touch
everything the more everything you [__]
your body gets for me but this is the
reason why I don't share joints with
them anymore because I don't trust this
fool did you see last night when I hit
the joint after he handed to me I did it
like this
at the theater because he smokes me with
everybody he does this [__] [__]
wipes her ass in his face he does a
bunch of [__] Bro every day no every
time the Raiders play he gets Ash and he
gets into the game
last Sunday yeah oh she's like wise
though he knows things like when he he's
like yeah
no no but you know you're right bro
there's a lot of things that I mean that
I've connected with since I was younger
and you know what I mean I'm I'm Not
Afraid bro I'm Not Afraid except you
might get sick once a year basically
that's why you're three times bro what
the [__] are you talking I'm telling you
this right now lately just because this
new covert should hit now they're like
yeah I've been nonstick maybe once a
year I'll get it or you know or [__]
yeah some [__] kicks in but I mean nah
that's nothing wrong I think when I was
smaller younger I [__] have gotten
sick where a fog bro I literally I
shouldn't probably I shouldn't even be
here you know what I mean so you know
get more sick that's cool and now I mean
now since I've ever got since I've
gotten sick like that back in this when
I was younger Bro [__] it's like
it just doesn't phase me no more you
know oh what that the horrible story
that you went over on episode this first
episode I believe in uh New Orleans
VooDoo oh no no that was that was even
different that was another type of
sickness but I mean even when I was
younger I've been to some [__] where
like God damn bro I'm seeing [__]
throughout my house and I'm [__]
seeing these like these weird ass [__]
bro and explain it's so good just they
want from [__] beans I don't know I
don't know like I said I was sick and
I'm seeing [__] like
bro everything every [__] everything
you could imagine bro every [__]
character back in the days that you
could think of [__] [__] role Kermit
the Frog bro chilling right there in my
[__] like on my bed like do they give
you like strong medicine too or you were
just tripping this is just my [__]
what I'm seeing like just what I'm
visioning and I'm seeing it bro it's
real it was real do you have like a
horrible fever uh you know what
maybe maybe not bro because if I had
fear I know my Mom would [__] put
[__] you know oh she'll my you know
my mom's making sure that's cool
it's called imagination now he could
have been tripping out though if he had
a baby or something imagination
but this [__] was real bro I mean you're
telling me you just respond Kermit the
Frog in your bed and just for you oh bro
more than that just a lot of different
[__] bro and I'm just like what the [__]
what is all this [__] going on in here
like just you know and like it from
there it just it gradually just changed
and changed like from seeing like
characters it changed to seeing others
[__] type of [__] whoa and whoa
now as I got older you know it just
everything just forgot when he was a kid
he was also eating mushroom gummies
that's this is really what happened he
was eating mushrooms he thought there
was Flintstone vitamins and they were
flip Stone vitamins he was getting
shit-faced all the time this was telling
me I could see like you know when I was
kidding she ghosts and [__] not Kermit
the Frog well you know what no this was
this happened once I've literally seen
like all these characters one day in my
room everywhere bro [__] some houses
everywhere bro it was just like what the
[__] like what happened I wasn't
dreaming bro because I mean [__] I
literally remember [__] you know
going to my mom's room and waking her up
and telling her like [__] I'm still
looking I'm like don't you see it she's
like what are you talking about oh you
were insane to this kid huh you were
crazy so what was he doing though he's
just down there [__] just like what
oh gee like you know what was he scary
just crazy [__] bro I mean I'm not
saying [__] they were like talking to
me no because they were just there and
I'm like [__] am I tripping or what is
this you know I mean and you know now I
would think ah maybe I was dreaming you
know what I mean I'm like [__] no I
wasn't [__] dreaming bro I could see
if you're talking about ghosts dead
people relative you're talking about
[__] characters yeah you know One
Time characters
when I seen the character I was just
like what the [__] is this is some kind
of like you know but I was I was still
young but you understand I was [__]
maybe like [__] five four years old
you ever seen the movie Donnie Darko oh
uh you know what you're seeing some
scary rabbits
no
but
I've seen some [__] [__] bro you know
what I mean but I don't pay attention
but hold on so this was when you were
sick yeah uh you know what
or just you know nah you know what I was
probably nah you know because I like I
said yeah they say fever when you get
fever so much you can [__] oh wait
if you have that much fever and you're
seeing [__] [__] I remember [__] you
had a fever when you were hallucinating
all this no no I didn't because I know
that if I did have a fever I would have
[__] my mom would have me [__]
with rags and [__] you know everybody
yeah like because there was other
moments when I had fever [__] had me
this [__] potatoes and [__] the
potato [__] don't work yeah you know
what I mean you know [__] back then
they thought [__] all the [__] work
so you know yeah you know [__] but
not you know back then no I wasn't
[__] I didn't have no fever but I'll
figure out this wake up and I'll be like
God damn like where in the [__] where am
I you know what I mean so when did it
stop it it might have stopped maybe [__]
when I was like about six six years old
seven years old
like it like uh [__] um
it just changed like in a scary way like
they're [__] with you or like no no
no no that wouldn't even know did you
ever try to interact
no I'll just like walk this was like
well it's like if you were at Disneyland
and you're going through a [__]
oh [__] right [__] like that so as I
wake up and I'm looking like what the
[__] is all this [__] yeah but that
sounds like a free Disneyland tickets
I'm walking to my parents room and
looking like Dad it's a trip it's like
get in there and I'm like I can't sleep
I go you know what are all these [__]
what are all these things right here
full of [__] so I don't just [__] go
to sleep you know what I mean [__] but
then I remember I'll be like I'll look
up and I'll be like God damn they're
still staring at you [__] what the [__]
is this did it look like people in
costumes from Disneyland are they
looking they look like the real [__]
character [__] [__] bro it was like
like Kermit was little or he wasn't in a
big costume no it was like still the
same cake little same [__] saying that
that's just bad [__] [__] just
walking along it's just some crazy [__]
bro I don't know maybe [__] like I
said who knows maybe [__] I think
it's kind of cool I was just like Howie
Mandel and uh Ben Savage lives under the
bed little monsters yeah or uh yeah well
you know maybe even my mind back then
was just so [__] um
you know what I mean because like I said
[__] out [__] like I could [__] when
I was young bro I could [__] find a
pencil and a [__]
something I could in my own head I could
make that [__] to characters and I would
just play with that you know it's like
oh I'll do some certain toys and I could
do you know I mean so my mind would just
[__] like I would just [__]
literally I want to say [__] um
just another level bro of thinking I
think at that age your your body your
soul is so pure that you know you you
could you're allowed to see [__] like
that I mean and then after I believe
after you hit the real world and the
cussing and all that [__] comes in and
you start seeing bad [__] and all that
that's when [__] you know you kick
into this [__] world you know I hate
that that's why you know I look at
little kids still you know from certain
age and down those are little angels you
know for sure I don't want my
four-year-old to stay where she's at so
badly oh Amy so she's in her own little
Universe of just innocence and that's
the [__] that's the best bro
I see that she see [__] that she's just
not even telling you because she just
don't even know how to explain to you
just like I hadn't I didn't know I
explained too it's my mom or nothing and
I just made like [__] trip up that's
interesting to think about
goddamn yeah because it's just so pure
bro it's so so pure it's once you hit
this world of realness and everything
bro it's just so evil here but one thing
I don't understand Dan is the characters
like I know we keep reiterating the same
but I'm saying it like six times
stop but that's why I wish I could have
saw that [__] that's why I wish Kermit
was chilling in my room bro are you
kidding me if red and Stimpy were just
sitting there I'm like hey man hey can
we
trying to hang out
my sister that's what I would have been
like all these characters where's donkey
going to [__] that my sister's here go
beat the [__] out already do something
damn
I wish I had homies like that damn we're
on we're still on this
guys the NFL playoffs are here the Wild
Card Weekend is here there's no better
place to go than DraftKings Sportsbook
with the road to Super Bowl 57 draftking
is ready to kick off the weekend and you
already know the official sports betting
partner of the NFL the dope as usual
podcast has officially teamed up with
DraftKings to bring you a brand new
offer right now every new customer that
signs up and places a bet of five
dollars gets an automatic 200 to bet all
new and existing customers can get a no
sweat bet every single day of Wild Card
Weekend right now even if your team
loses this weekend you get a free ten
dollars back to bet with deals like this
why would you bet anywhere else for the
NFL come to DraftKings Sportsbook as you
guys know the Packers suck this year and
we're not making the playoffs but right
now I'm really really hoping that
Marty's team the bills make it all the
way because it's been two seasons in a
row already that it's been really close
so right now guys do us a favor from the
doubles usual podcast Go download
DraftKings Sportsbook app and when you
do use code Yola and all new customers
remember bet five dollars get an
automatic 200 to bet instantly guys it's
wild car weekend remember go to
draftkingsportsbook download the app use
code yellow bet five dollars get an
automatic two hundred dollars plus all
new and existing customers if you lose
even if your team loses you get ten
dollars back this week and only with
DraftKings Sportsbook minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see notes
for details
I got some more generals tomorrow
that I got right now is outside
ridiculous I haven't seen good [__]
OG from you oh you're gonna see what's
19. tonight you're gonna drink a little
bit
you want to try it you want to try it
with the mineral water
very [__] I think I'd puke really
yeah just watered down I don't know what
I mean I don't know unless you you like
it I mean I don't it's like I just write
down that bottle was full when we
started the show guys OG doesn't drink
there was like three shots left so
there's like three threes
it is like three episodes yeah
it's not the same model
oh this blueberry is crazy yeah
you want your water down or no
pretty good I'm good yeah he's not soft
here's the mineral water
I'll [__] drink that whole bottle
right now I'm gonna start saying that
yeah I bet you couldn't clean my room
right now I bet you couldn't even clean
my whole house OG
[__] weak ass why but you couldn't
even scrub my whole floor right now
could you clean this whole Warehouse I
bet you couldn't
could you do it
do it let's see
I take the reverse psychology oh gee man
you wouldn't even I bet you couldn't
even give me a whole pound there's no
way you could it's a king guy
possible it'd be impossible you have to
be too cool to do that
man yeah actually um
no okay
that's something good he's got nothing
what do you mean that's what we're
talking about oh before we [__]
started we're back on right now yeah
technically yes
I said Edward back all right my bad [__]
yeah you don't pay attention to [__]
it's amazing I love it eat the rest of
the hash gummy you're not even driving
Mindy's driving he's a [__] guy
Mindy's driving what how much 15 what
there's only they're five milligrams
yeah that's five 50 milligrams no I said
15. if you eat them all 15. and look it
didn't even hit you it didn't even hit
you you pooped it out
[__]
that's what that break was all about
otherwise guys so what are you think
into two little champs
yo this is the goofy [__] I ever thought
real cute it's so stupid
that's the goofiest [__] ever all right
let's get back serious
[Laughter]
you know as taxes you can't stop this
right now everybody's just in your head
imagine oh gee
um
[Laughter]
[__] up your hands
it's eating your brain up oh
God damn I love it so
how do you feel about the [__] was that
are you coming with your border patrols
all right
not yet back to where you at continue
Marty no I already have somewhat of an
idea but you can elaborate on this where
are you at with superstitious [__] in
your head count numbers knocking on wood
something was falling off our [__] okay
sorry go all right so overall
superstitious [__] going on in your head
knocking on wood count number is even
odd numbers and yeah all day you want to
know how much of a white girl OG is he
drinks wine Starbucks and he carries
crystals
take out the [__] Starbucks I'm not a
Starbucks he drinks hella teas and
coffees from Starbucks sorry Pete's
Coffee I don't [__] with Starbucks peach
coffee where do you go Starbucks I see
you every Sunday morning on your drives
with a cup in your hand driving
I don't know that's my beard
never mind he's not driving let's not
say OG was just driving let's say he was
parked
[__] [__] every [__] Sunday
he's like you know what Sunday I feel
fancy
I'm gonna sippy cup in today
every second
that's me I'm looking so what I'll do is
on Sunday I'll wake up I'll get a beard
I mean I'm not I mean I'm not doing I'm
not drunk driving you know I'll tell you
that now don't [__] stop stop
speaking about the whole thing listen to
this oh what I'll do is I'll drink a
beard while I'm way too much to wear go
have breakfast and I have breakfast
literally not even in a [__] mile
away from my house so stop at the store
grab a beer I'll pour it in my in my cup
so they don't [__] having a cup get
to a [__] place have breakfast and
boom done but I always have you know
I'll have my beer while I'm going over
there because
I'm gonna have breakfast and I check it
right there in the park and then I go
inside and have breakfast yeah you know
and that's it I'm done drinking you know
what I mean for breakfast well I'm sorry
but this is the [__] that you don't see
in Buffalo this is the [__] you don't
see when he's hung over and [__] up he
mixes kamado and a Budweiser or whatever
the [__] he drinks and he that's it I
feel better no you don't feel better you
just get [__] up again and forgot that
you felt like [__] I feel better
but you don't [__] feel that you know
then later on you gradually just stop
drinking and it just goes away that
sounds like methadone clinic but at home
yeah sounds like you got a problem
alcohol has medicine for the alcohol
goddamn
yeah you should be he breaks tables
like casinos
so what's up you superstitious or what
you're knocking on wood you're breaking
wood tables yeah [__] yeah for sure
always bro
the crystals what kind of numbers [__]
you got going on are you like counting
even an odd numbers
any number that appears to me any number
that's in front license plates
everything I would go by all that but
does it what I'm thinking not if I'm I'm
gonna if I just see a license plates and
I see a number you know but my thoughts
are not where I'm gonna whatever I'm
thinking I see that number it's nothing
hey do me a favor put that mic in front
only if I'm um there you go yep there
you go if I'm thinking about something
in my head or trying to you know do some
[__] or whatever and I see numbers and I
get my answers back like that like
sometimes I'll have it where I'm
thinking about a specific number and
then they say it at the same time of the
[__] that I'm listening to old time is
that what you're talking about dude the
last time I was seeing license plates in
certain numbers like cool I saw the
certain number that didn't matter but if
you're sticking to something looks up
and goes oh my God it's right in front
in front of me then it matters signs are
around all day but do they matter to you
I see signs on the freeway but that's
not my [__] exit yeah like [__] that
sign that's basically the way I think
about it yeah yeah I mean [__] same [__]
here you know I mean it's just it
depends what I'm doing like where where
my where my mind where my thoughts are
at the moment then that's when I'll then
I'll take then I'll start looking at
numbers and [__] if I get them
in front of me then I know okay that's
that's a sign and I already know what
usually some numbers mean do you believe
in like numerology and [__] you seem
like sorry that yeah so what does that
what does that mean to you
well [__] that means a lot to me it
tells me a lot who I was in my past life
you know what I mean and um like
you know what who I would like back back
then you know I believe that we all been
I mean everybody that's like all of us
in this room I believe that we've been
somehow in our past life
we've we've interact together we worked
together somehow and now we're all now
we're still brought back to this place
but in just different forms though you
know what I mean and and our next life
it's gonna be a whole different form
again you know what I mean and that's
the way people
maybe not no yeah no I I feel that
everybody that comes into your life is
somebody that was in your past life in
your other life that you oh for sure I
feel I met and know people that I've met
past lives like Rosie's grandpa [__] for
sure wow come on
here for sure I mean and maybe he was
like yo you did such a good deed when
you reincarnate you're gonna
smoke weed for a living or something
you're like yo me saving that kid in the
40s you know what I mean like I don't
know what it is because I think it's
[__] like that all the time
even in your past life
they were probably even enemies of yours
and now in this like different context
but but they still play the same role
you know what I mean it's like a Call of
Duty yeah it's like it's it's still an
enemy but it's undercover enemy but he's
here you know what I mean damn therefore
looked at me from this glass
[Laughter]
I swear looking like that you know look
at [__] like yeah
um
yeah one time anybody anybody who um
you don't mean nobody for no reason
they'll be like aha moments where you'll
get a synchronicity like that where it's
like I'm [__] thinking about
something so specific and it just popped
up in what I'm listening to it or saw
and I'll just take that as like you're
in the right place you're doing the
right thing just keep doing what you're
doing
that's just how you know I let that
because sometimes it's just like what
the [__] I'm talking about maybe two
three times a year if you ever had like
these [__] up thoughts and you're like
what the [__] am I thinking of course
you know day every day yeah you know in
what context
you know just [__] that you just didn't
want to happen of course I think I
consider worst case all right oh [__]
today's the day you're gonna die
yeah worst case scenario can you do that
all the time like
like it's almost my OS it's almost right
or today that [__] today is the day
that I gotta look out for [__] this
you know yeah and you know [__] like
that you know yeah sorry I forgot just
something you know what I mean I think
about [__] like that and then I scale it
back to just like being grateful for
just having exactly think about that oh
yeah no for sure no I mean what you just
gotta do I mean because
that's not really actual signal you send
out you know what I mean it's more just
like a thought yeah there's a difference
between like an attention and just a
random thought that keeps [__]
popping yeah exactly that's why you know
sometimes you know people [__] up and
what they do is they they um they
mistaken their thoughts with their what
they're sending out and they send it out
instead of you know they think it's a
thought but no you're actually sending
that [__] out
that's why I always tell [__]
that I know when they get all negative
and start talking [__] and being dicks
or being like bro you have no idea that
you're doing it again it's gonna happen
again and keep happening all the
negative [__] because all you do is
talk about other people how they're
[__] up when you're not doing
anything about yourself when they said
last night there was a little girl that
Mr Beast like they did this thing this
like charity actor in the show when they
said she was like 15 to make a battle in
cancer since she was two oh oh I was
like yeah
I was like what the [__] so the girls in
a wheelchair and they brought her up and
donated to her family and stuff but just
when I thought about that like
damn like just circumstances like that
that you do it into the mic louder as
[__] one morning that's this trademark
move with this [__] Jesus but he's so
sincere moment talking to the little
girl
oh my God
that's pretty cool
that was that's like a soundboard he was
that was emphasis for how nice it was
multiple
I just grind up a little bit Yeah the
hell's mad at you yeah Chris Tucker
strain and also a few joints
I don't want smoke yeah you want to
smoke after you hit my mom I wipe it
[__] just because I don't trust
him you hear his germaphobe [__] he
[__] licks the ground at Subways and
[__] oh those are good microbes down
there nah bro we were in Vegas on this
trip he his feet were planted he put his
chest on the ground and just slid across
the ground dirty [__] this was hella
dirty pretty much
slip he ran
[Laughter]
out
you know this whole time now people
imagine you shitty
people matched you sprinting and sliding
on your stomach down the street that's
funny as a [__] by the way oh just got
hella weird ass tattoos too so now you
can think of you you should post that
weird tattoos you have a gigantic
octopus coming across your chest what
are you talking about that's the [__]
multitasking [__] octopus you
don't multitask though bro bro I can't
talk to you while you're playing a game
this is the the epitome of not
multitasking what's up bro no no I'm
just playing the Call of Duty what's up
what's going on no you don't speak
stop Jody
you know what it's because look it I'm
talking I'm talking I'm talking back in
my days like you know when when I first
had my kids and [__] and you know what I
mean yeah I used to [__] I was
working [__] I was uh worked out I
was a dog [__] uh supervisor at a doc
I was a [__] um I was a pool man
[__] too I had no more right I
[__] sold weed so I had three
[__] jobs in one [__] day
okay that's not multitasking doing
multiple things at once exactly you're
not cleaning the pools
I'm taking my [__] pools and fools
people are pulling up already at the
houses that they know I'm there I'm
already bam here you go okay you know
what I mean I'm [__] then I pulled to
my job and then people are coming in
there asking for an application where
they're just there to pick up you know
the [__] secretary's like damn you
know we don't have we ran out of uh um
like any applications today and there's
people just going into my [__] job
picking weed up and asking for an
application multitask Force out there
yeah yeah so [__] your [__] like that
you know what so that's why I got you
all right that is multitasking just
[__] is that literally what uh hold
on just you have a literal octopus
tattoo it's across and that's what it
represents chest no I got one across
right here but they use the octopus's
face is Danny Trejo it's a whole octopus
remember his head of the tortoise and
Breaking Bad
I'm not that high maybe that's why yeah
but you know that's what it was that you
know that's why I got the octopus for
yeah I literally felt like the moment I
left my house to go [__] it you know to
do my pools because that was my first
thing I was busy like [__] it it was
just like [__] bro the day went so quick
because [__] just I'll tell you right
now I would break down maybe about
two pounds in [__] one one [__]
one day get the [__] out of here but
what increments are they going out in
just like bro half ounces ounces is
[__] even Ace even [__] what
you're doing pools of houses yeah yeah
this was all this was all like uh
Friendly Hills over here [__] lahara
[__] uh Orange County uh Anaheim
Hills you know what I mean and you know
that's where all my peeps were at too
you know I mean everybody like oh [__]
could you bring me two ounces tomorrow
could you bring me a Nails tomorrow next
you know even even some of my pool
customers that would make them my
[__] customers
it's pretty safe well actually I would
do about uh 30 30 38 pools almost 40
pools a day God damn what now you're
telling me you're cleaning 40 pulls a
day roll that joint stop lying 40 pulls
the [__] name
that you said was an OG I could tell
from the bottom of that weed that that
structure is not OG fully stop turn the
nug on the bottom look at that give me
the other nut let me see that what look
at the bottom of the nug throw it
yes
you're gonna tell me
right now that this is the Fire OG that
you're saying or is this the nugs that
you brought out of there
what that's out of that jar right no
this nugget of his bag huh yeah this is
different weed I can see by this oh yeah
no this is not the one you had that's
not the one yo I've never done this
let me see if I can flick this new sport
right here come on come on do it do it
do it you're not gonna go like this go
like this come on come on just do it
real quick while we're on the show we're
not doing anything this is a loose
episode
we were all really [__] up from the
Ted talk I'm like oh my God we didn't do
an episode yet we've been so busy like
oh gee come over here fool let's talk
about some your Danny Trejo tattoo all
OG's tattoos mean something and uh he
carries crystals I'm pretty sure his
name's Becky
at this point your name is Becky OG okay
can you put your [__] fingers up so I
get the score
come on just because the Raiders can't
kick let me [__] try
give me one
let me let me do oh you want to do this
I said it 40 [__] times
oh you want to do that come on just one
one little time
with your teeth
if you pull out your fingers farther I
can make it come on it's either that or
it's gonna hit you randomly when you're
rolling I don't think it's gonna make
you more all right let me see if I can
hit you in the face then no then put
your fingers up come on
I'll make it
oh
that was that was a good shot that was a
good shot if the field goal was up you
would he would have cared we would oh
that smells delicious this is amazing
this is like a choice he's going crazy
yeah hey oh yeah
so by the way OG telling doing 40 pulls
a day I I really did those pull-ups last
episode that's the same as me I did
those bullets I really did them no you
did yeah you're busting out like 40 50 a
[__] minute I would do 40 pools a day
and um so I would always take somebody
with me right to homina go pick up oh
somebody else did it you know I would
pay one of my helpers all the time I'll
take somebody I'll take you there my
little nephew I'll take my you know my
compiler I'll take my [__] my you
know my cousin or someone he pointed at
me
oh my cousin nah so you know I'm [__]
we just [__] um do the pool then we
would we would say yeah he's gonna be in
and out service that microphone
we're going in and we're going [__]
out and [__] quick so you didn't
clean the pool no no no [__] yeah no no
we do me a favor move that microphone in
front of you there you go it was still
[__] do the poop but it was [__]
we would do it [__] fast bro fast and
quick get the [__] quick little skin so
basically you to do a [__] job so you
can sell weed faster
and you made your little right there
sold the second [__] left
there's still Leaf floating around
man no you know what um I will do pools
[__] like from eight eight in the
morning you know from seven in the
morning to two o'clock in the afternoon
two o'clock in the afternoon go back
home [__] re-up get more weed go to
my second job
yeah well you guys were stealing so much
that they uh put cameras in to see who
was stealing and then you all got fired
that's a different place yeah
because that story is hilarious which
one was it you tell me which place I
went through a few [__] crazy
thoughts that's what I'm saying which
stock did I tell you which one was like
damn I wish you get all the news yo can
I tell the story real quick go you know
what no I want you tell me the story of
why you got fired for sweaters
you told me this [__] recently oh it's a
sitcom can you just [__] just say it
butt rolling so we were so we were all
coming up everybody's coming up in this
company bro I was [__] there's Nike
sweaters and [__] and we all got Nike
sweaters and [__] next thing you know
they say hey
we just opened up a new company in uh
Fontana do you guys want to go down
there and I can work over there he's
he's actually gonna be me man [__]
managers whatever so we're like [__] you
know yeah let's go okay you guys you
guys have an interview
um you guys have an interview tomorrow
you know at [__] 9 A.M so we're like
all right cool well
we all [__] met up over there at 9am
and we're all [__] wearing the same
[__] Nike sweater this [__]
left off 92 of the story everybody all
he did was tell you what happened at the
end you have no idea why he was there
what he was doing my God all right well
before that we were coming up on sway
we're coming up on [__] they were
stealing dogs yeah we're looking at the
dock so [__] hey we're coming up
[__] we had sweaters we had jerseys
we had anything you want bro [__]
good [__] everything everything I went
to so we got these [__] sweaters and
we're like [__] it next thing you know
we're like you know what
we're about to take we're supposed to
take these sweaters because these
sweaters are like very expensive like
maybe 120 bucks
so we took a few for us and they were
[__] the rest were like you know what
[__] that you know I can't take I'm not
gonna take them so I tell this guy you
know what go throw them in the trash
just because you know you don't want to
[__] you don't want to [__] leave
no evidence wrong this guy thrown back
in the trailer send the trailer off to
Fontana where we're going to go get a
job in the next few weeks we're not
thinking about it so you know supervisor
the manager or whatever the regional uh
yeah [__] the boss over there [__]
he gets his [__] trailer with
sweaters that were open and okay cool
well now we get off for these positions
to go back over there to rent it over
there we're like [__] it well nobody
even knows but we all [__] it was a
cold [__] morning we all [__]
pulled up to the [__] parking lot we
all get off at the same [__] sweater
bro everybody's wearing the same [__]
Stones [__] manager [__]
supervisor [__] spots it out right
away as we're Foods were trying to
change the sweaters and [__]
I mean I appreciate the effort even the
second swing at that you still have so
many I still don't know what happened
can I just oh my God
oh my God
they were stealing so much they set up
cameras oh gee and his friends oh no
that's another spot that's another oh
God that's doing so much [__] that they
had to investigate on who was stealing
all the Nike sweaters and instead they
promoted these guys because like we got
a filter out these people these are our
good guys they sent them to the new spot
and they kept trying to figure it out
and they all wore the same [__]
stolen Nike sweater on the same day to
their interview and they all go are
those the sweaters that we're looking
for you guys are [__] fired and
that's what happened I'm gonna [__]
box you I don't understand now you get
it thank you [__]
[__] this was our Ted Talk That was
he watches cameras all day to find
weasel tits he's finding himself that's
why he knows so well he's a [__]
expert yeah you're like Ocean's [__]
dress
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God your socks are getting higher
by the minute it's like Spider-Man if
you smoke off an OG joint it's like
getting bit by a radioactive spider
oh my God that's a really good [__]
bit I wish we had like graphic people to
do that
that's pretty [__] funny I
think
pro clubs tag sticks out
we got a pro club on right now
but
just gonna hit you up tomorrow morning
that's it that is [__] amazing I love
every piece of that what are we at oh my
God
130 we're trying to do an hour because
we have tomorrow one day sorry I'm sorry
Marty has to edit this in less than the
day because Ted Talk [__] us not
[__] us [__] us up is like four or
five days straight we didn't do anything
but it so we didn't do a podcast we were
gonna do this one on Wednesday I'm proud
of that [__] speech I can't wait for
you guys to hear that yeah I'm stoked
I'm stoked but also we learned a lot
about OG
a lot today yeah what'd you learn about
we learned that you
have live laugh love deep inside of you
but you just won't let it out yeah your
live laugh love is covered by a Mexican
flag
that's nice
yo if you imagine OG did his own podcast
like Bill Burr does there's a comedian
OG called named Bill Burr he goes in his
basement Monday Morning podcast goes in
his basement
no camera and just talks into the
microphone for like an hour every Monday
that's it about what the [__] on his
mind and half of it's like you know
it's been half of it she's just so upset
right could you imagine oh geez Monday
Morning podcast you know man just get
out there stop being a little [__]
[__] and start with weasel titsing
around with your life
that'd be sick you gotta have it be like
he doesn't know it's recording and he's
just bitching about [__] yeah did you
notice this whole episode you've been
turned away from the camera the whole
[__] time thanks for that it's gonna
be great to edit together I'm sorry he's
talking right into this [__] one that
keeps dying okay so that's perfect so we
can't get any of the angles maybe it's
so sick but besides that you didn't get
all weird and get all shy and [__]
curl up this episode I know but the
mic's so far from me that's the only
thing bring it to you hola here you go
there you go there you go it's moves it
moves did you guys steal these
uh no I don't know they probably didn't
have these back then
back in uh 2004. so Dan that's I'm sorry
that's crazy we learned a lot about him
he finds these thieves because he's
looking for himself
he's looking for his former self like I
know what you're doing I used to do that
yeah I'm looking for myself this is this
crazy you're finding yourself this is
gonna be his [__] Ted talk but I
found myself and he had gotten away for
it with six pounds already so I knew
what I had to do I had to beat the [__]
out of him
foreign
don't get me wrong [__] at any moment I
could always do what I always do you
know I mean I can always [__]
multitask there's no but you're not
meant to as you get older you're meant
to like earn more and do less at least
that's what you do yeah but you know
what if you really think about it it
still it doesn't stop brother multi like
it's like you know multitasking never
stops just like him you no matter what
you guys might I don't know if you guys
don't see it but you guys are
multitasking bro oh yes what are you
doing you're with your family your kid
you're being a father your husband you
know you're working yeah then you're
trying to [__] you know just [__]
Marty's a bus driver during the day
[__] multitasking world you know what
I mean yeah for damn sure very true
that's the way I look at it you know
that's why I got an octopus you know I
mean [__] I feel like we all already
with all our octopuses in one way or
another symbolic that was one of them
and then the other one is just you know
the octopus is just you know it's one of
the smartest creatures I was gonna say
that in the ocean you know what I mean
and uh the way he catches his praise and
[__] you know he's a fool he's a fool
oh speak speaking of the ocean
next question okay
if you had to solo pick one deep sea
cave diving or skydiving if you had to
do it alone alone
I would say uh and you're forced you'd
rather deep see yeah well that's the
first time we've heard that the scene
doesn't scare the anomaly the ocean
don't scare you are you [__] go in
there I go in there I do it all the time
I'll go in there no problem no
no problem you're just you're good you
see he's good with like just the use one
like he doesn't no he just doesn't care
about sharks but that's what that means
though if I get bit by a shark away me I
mean the Sharks it's like getting bit by
a shark that's one in a million right
it's like a [__] in a plane crash you
know you're you're more bound to get in
a car accident and die there than
[__] get bit by damn your odds thing
you're really sticking to it yeah well
cause that sucks you know when people
tell me that all day you're more likely
to crash on the way but I'm driving the
car if I at least I'll be mad at myself
the pylon is like hey man you having a
bad day
[__] you
but it's very rare yeah it's very rare
but I don't want to be on that very rare
flight I mean it's I look at it like
this
to me look at it like this it's a
[__] it if that's what it is bro
that's a [__] it's a it's a ticket
bro you you [__] win that golden
ticket to your next life and which is
gonna be amazing better than this life
so [__] if that's not drive with OG no
more you know what I mean [__] dude
if it's our time it's our time Brody red
light [__] a red light you know what I
mean I mean
I feel you yeah whether if it's a plane
crash it's gonna happen or if that
accident's gonna happen or it's gonna be
that guy that's going to shoot you
that's the way that's your exit out of
this life bro
you know what I mean
no big um thank you that's all three of
you shaking hang on no
but it's okay
I think where they think I mean like
they say we're all I mean we're all
gonna die right I mean [__] we're no
matter where we can never run from that
[__] you just don't want to work we can
avoid the [__] that's the opposite of
that is but even though regardless it's
still there and we all don't know how
this will dies first well we don't know
right he just doesn't Dodge the
breakfast I'm just saying you know you
know living in this world you don't know
bro it's [__] you know it's a [__]
it's like tell me when you when you
decide to go put gas sometimes you think
about oh [__] you know you think ahead
before you get to that gas station
you're already thinking what what could
happen or what you should do in case
something happens of course you know I
mean so it's the same [__] bro if it's
gonna happen it's gonna [__] happen
there's times where you're probably
putting gas you're like [__] bro right
now easily somebody could just [__]
rob my ass and you know what I mean and
it could [__] happen so yeah it's
it's there bro it's just it's there you
can't you can't run from that you can
literally run from it
he's talking about worrying about things
I'm just saying no I'm quite worried
about it I don't know it is what it is
that's [__] wild from you
me not to worry when I was going to
Beijing he was trapped he didn't bring
nothing you want me to ride with you I'm
like I'm just driving to Las Vegas and
you're saying not to worry I'm saying
because yeah because I know the type of
world that's why like I said like I told
him [__] you know [__] even though we're
going to Vegas [__] I like to still
bring my [__] with me you know [__]
doesn't matter that form I'm saying in
general like you worry all the time it's
not that I worry about but I tried I try
to I take my precaution thank you
but I'm not but at the point when it
comes down I'm not gonna be [__] oh
[__] not it is what it is are you saying
you wouldn't be scared to go deep sleep
kid no if not you know at all no no not
at all no no problem I mean I I jumped
in the beach [__] at night different
different and you know you can't see
nothing you can't see that you know even
in the daytime you can't see nothing you
know oh hell I honestly you gotta pay me
at least
so much
1.5 in cash to get in the [__] ocean
at night I'm not getting under enough
for less than that it's not like it's
just sharks it's so much everything on
earth that could be under there right
now thinking of being in [__]
Darkness with water I feel like a little
kid that's about to get jumped like no
I'm just gonna get jumped the water
itself was gonna curl up and down the
temperature of the water even a GTA
under the water I I have I can't I
[__] can't do it I can't do the POV
view I can't
it [__] me up dude I don't know what it
is I can't do the underwater
Heights get me like that when I see
people just seen a video of someone who
hides it gets me like oh what the [__]
yeah what I mean not that a [__] um
jumping off a plane wouldn't interest me
I mean [__] I would love to do that
either yeah you would do that yeah I'll
learn all these new things that I talked
to him before and he's like no hell no
Brody I never thought he was like this
are you doing opposite day on me today
no actually I would jump off a plane why
not but it sounds like [__] why not
you gotta do that I think he's [__]
trolling sounds like a vlog today bro I
think yeah
I think he's [__] with us I mean
honestly I mean seriously you got it bro
what what the [__]
have you ever done any extreme [__] like
this that we don't know about
uh no I mean [__] I mean I jumped in the
in you know we've been in the ocean [__]
like that yeah I've done that that's
freaking I've never been an extreme man
but I mean well I mean
oh do you go on those big ass rides that
drop
oh yeah yeah oh you do you [__] with
that yeah oh yeah
he doesn't give a [__] yeah yeah you
don't care you don't care about germs he
don't care about the ocean or the
environment
he's won with the [__] environment
yeah I'm cool with the environment I
don't [__] with the environment
you mean you don't [__] with it or you
like you don't do bad like you don't
[__] with it like you don't step on ants
I don't kill bugs
oh can I tell you some [__] that
happened real quick I was at my mom's
and I looked down the toilet there's
three ants walking by and I was like oh
get away but I'm not gonna kill him kill
bugs and right when I was about to go I
stopped there was an ant and another ant
following it and the Ant in front of it
was holding oh it's a homie that was
like busted in half and it was like
broken but you can see his legs moving
and he was holding him carrying his ass
off
like some war movie [__] and I picked
him up on a paper towel and I put him
outside I'm like yo you guys are taking
your homie back to the [__] home oh I
probably should have let him go
they'll make their way back I just
didn't want people to step on them but
dude it's like a war movie God damn it
was [__] insane actually
radio yeah anyway but it's a world it's
a different world of course I've seen
bugs live I told you I saved a little
lizard's life once right from a spider
that [__] was true oh yeah you can't eat
around you can't get it somewhere else
spider yeah I'll wet the chef spiders
[__] you spiders
I know they got to eat over there yeah
as long as you don't you don't [__] with
it it's cool
that's their world huh do you have a
tattoo spider double elbows no
elbows up when I met him that's what was
playing when I met him he was doing this
and he walked up to me and he was elbows
up it's Lean Like A Cholo song Marty I
don't know if you know that one
yeah no no no I don't know I have a I
have a dragon and I have a oh that is a
dragon huh he has my name too my middle
name did you see the new Avatar
actually no I haven't I've been I've
been wanting to see it but [__] I
haven't been make sure you got it for
like three hours make sure you got 10
hours yeah that's why that's why I
haven't watched it because [__] I don't
wanna but the title spoiler but it could
have been about [__] half of what it
was
L elbows up they didn't enter the water
until two hours in that budget
oh [__] really
I was offended how [__] long it was
like you're I do not need to be here
this I was offended by how long it was
was the best thing he could have said
I'm offended that you mean yeah yeah
when I heard about [__] how long was
I was actually gonna go watch it and
then when I found out how long it was
like oh maybe not like [__] yeah real
quick it's a little too much we all just
started talking this episode
good job you need to sit here and go
like all right so these stories and that
story we just kind of Let It Go yeah
this is a good one and this Bull's not
sitting here all nervous because we're
not questioning him this is better is
your fourth time on here is it I don't
know I want to say fourth fistful
doesn't watch any of his episodes he
does I I have to tell him on our most
popular episodes he has two or three the
most returning guests of all time
and he don't even watch a little jerk
I'm not no one special I'm not doing
special
as he as he levitates
walks on water and just I'm just me
being me turns this back into a
teleports yeah oh teleports over there
refreshes our camera [__] charges it
up I ain't nobody special man touches it
it charges it edits our whole podcast
that's you I like your Grove Street hat
yeah that's like it all right last one
this is a new one last one go
where you at with things that you need
to fall asleep oh this is a new what is
this like I need a fan I need a certain
pillow or my neck's all [__] up is
there anything that you need to do every
night in order to fall asleep or not
have shitty sleep
face down
uh
um just [__] what else bro I think it's
a [__] phone bro basically
you need your phone to sleep no I mean
what I'll do is I'll just go through my
phone uh put some [__] um put some
music on what kind of music do you fall
asleep to I gotta know right now
classical music classicals you getting
smart in your sleep just all kinds of
[__] you actually wake up a lot smarter
next day I'm ready to [__] build a
bomb or something
yeah let's care about hygiene he only
cares about blowing [__] up so do you
fall asleep did you have do you have a
routine or do you like pass out on the
couch or do you like uh you know what
since I smoke a lot of OG all day long
usually you know I'll just [__] crash
up you know I have a crash freaking you
know whatever say [__] my living room
if I'm watching TV I crash out bathroom
floor maybe above [__] I could watch
maybe about a half hour or 45 minutes or
something and I'll Crush out if I've
been up to the whole day I mean and
that's basically [__] at the end of the
night that's when I only get to watch
maybe a little bit of TV and and that's
not even TV that's [__] just me
putting on a movie or something because
I don't even got no TV Mouse it's 2 A.M
you don't have a TV at your house
I don't know I have a TV fool oh but I
don't I don't I don't have a big table I
don't have the channels yeah oh hell no
no you have Netflix and [__] though yeah
just that yeah yeah I know because you
watch some of the same chairs right away
you stay up late though it's 2 A.M late
or are you caught up only on my days off
I could stay up late maybe two o'clock
sometimes three
you know on a depends on his [__] face
you know just overthinking [__] and just
uh I have like all kinds of [__] on my
head I don't go see maybe till like four
damn I want to get like maybe four hours
maybe at the most I can't function at
four hours hey you turn that mic towards
yourself well where's maybe uh no not
lower away from you four hours a day
it's like to leave something no those
times where [__] I only sleep two hours
and go and do a day yeah God damn yeah
and then still come home and [__] you
not bro that I [__] still can't sleep
till [__] [__] three in the
morning again bro cause you're like too
tired because my [__] mind is just
going bro just [__] it's weird
I don't know I'm just thinking about
everything bro everything bro
everything everything and everybody bro
you'd be surprised he doesn't smoke with
bongs no more he used to
he has no more bongs he's sitting there
puffing a joint every eight seconds
between Call of Duty how's he gonna go
to sleep hmm you're sitting there
playing games for an hour and then your
mind's supposed to go to bed you're
right I mean I could [__] you know no
this [__] I could take I could like I
said I could take a little rice screen
of artists so and I could not cry but I
mean my thing is uh no sometimes I just
got thinking to do but I gotta [__]
you know yeah they just gotta thinking
you know yeah is it effective or is it
time wasting just no no of course it
leads something else the next state you
know what I mean it always leads to
something you gotta get something out of
that world because if I would see it now
[__] that because like April will sit
there and watch these Murder Mysteries
and [__] and all night and just focus
your mind on that and I'm like you're
not getting anything out of this other
than [__] scared I had to stop
randomly I stopped scrolling this whole
week I didn't look at anything yeah and
you're doing the Ted talk [__] [__] yeah
so I do I had like 75 messages from two
days I didn't [__] check one of them
it really required to try to memorize
something [__] like that requires a true
lockout I don't [__] with that [__] yeah
I try to stay off my brain doesn't yeah
next time we need a Podium and we just
need to be able to read it and just if
it's going to be written out like that
for sure it was so low yeah it was too
much for my we did it but it was too
much to do it again
no way you can't do it again it was
great to do it yeah no I think what you
got to do is now
just just now just write your own notes
down right now as you're going and as
soon as you're practicing all that every
day share your net your next Ted Talk
could be [__] in a year from now but
you got all this [__] that you just been
memorizing and practicing with oh so
working on and working on and and that's
your [__] talk roll this that's how
you kill it well this is what happened
dude really because I think it was
behind the scenes this is what happened
quick
we wrote our whole speech two days
before Ted Talk Marty tooks the Ted Talk
Master Class
and then we both watch and realize we
are rewriting our entire [__] speech
the things we were put in our speech
they say the two things please don't do
in your speech this and this wait a
minute that's kind of a strong point I
was leading on oh [__] so we wrote he
rewrote our entire [__] basically with
just chunks of our stuff and replaced it
or we had to re do an entire speech on
Wednesday oh [__] we had seven note
cards each of full full [__] text
text blocks try to remember it all but
not even that we only had 48 Hours yeah
we had it done solid like oh let's take
the master class see what they got to
say he called her watch it call me back
like oh [__] because I think we need to
reevaluate our whole speech like [__]
you right so that's why we were
panicking we we didn't procrastinate we
did it we realized we needed to up it
make it better to fit the topic better
yeah
speech I still got the old speech it's
[__] easy for me because it's a story
time essentially
going through my own brain then we
rewrote it that's why we were stressed
out the whole [__] time yeah so I was
pacing for two hours just it's a little
confusing like the purpose of a TED Talk
is to express one clean idea yes that is
uniquely within you to place that idea
you would like this and how they do it
in the animation they're like they're
like an idea is a specific group of
neural pests like and they like animate
a specific little group of neural pass
and when you impart that idea in an
audience now that neural path formation
is now in their brains than it wasn't
before yeah yeah you like plant the seed
yes and that's the point of a TED Talk
one clean idea ideas worth sharing
within the theme of that evening who is
it was because as we did it we weren't
doing both pieces it's like oh we did
the idea but it doesn't correlate with a
theme directly made it a through line
you need to take a through line and that
what I loved about what they said in the
master class was think about yourself as
a tour guide around this idea yeah so
like we're guiding you around this idea
and bringing you back with a through
line our through line was the Hustler
why because the Hustler was the core of
the theme being able to start from
scratch in this age what matters what
qualities and then it just so happened
we're both some hustling ass
[__] our whole life so I was
able to take our took our lives and wove
it within the theme it worked out
Thursday night I told Ralph I was like
yo I feel like I'm on a school project
and I got teamed up with the smart kid
in class this [__] weaved our
words he took my words and just
place them in different parts and went
oh hell yeah we needed to make it way
more cohesive this way and then we had
to rewrite honestly 90 of the speech was
changed yeah yeah within the 48 Hours of
going on with that [__] dude
yeah we pulled
we were like a week out we're going dude
we got to really focus on knocking out
exactly what we wanted this video this
episode this video
imagine if two months ago you guys you
would have just been catching all those
points and catching all those yeah of
course yeah it would have been like how
people have their comedy routine
memorized they go out there and just do
it that's what you got to do so from
this point on that's how you guys just
got to do it right now just start taking
those points and start putting them
putting them down because on the next
one
bam you just [__] know for sure we
could do that same speech again that's a
great [__] oh for sure hours bro
that's our [__] yeah yeah
even the president of the United States
gets a Podium with his speech yeah
because valedictorians get their speech
it's about the ideas you don't want to
be like losing the good points of the
idea because of the like performance
aspects of it yes yeah so we went out
there with nothing so we're like and
then just real quick real quick
the light guy quit mid Ted talk because
something happened so they had somebody
else do it and they had it so bright I
couldn't think or see so I want to point
that out there so if you see the Ted
Talk you should be doing this there were
some elements
this is all turning away from here
yeah you couldn't really see anything
yeah it was so far
no it was like putting your eye up to
your [__] headlight like when the
optometrists yeah when they do the look
at your eye that's why I'll see you
about that when I see I was like [__]
bro oh no they feel you know it would
have been better above us
like like 20 less would it not so like
when I went up there first and went so
that Justice whoa yes it was an orange
Class theater they might have that for
the people that [__] they you know
that they get [__] stage-face that's
what I was thinking
you know it's like you just honestly I
would rather saw the audience yeah I
want to see people's faces I want to
point them [__] want to say
some [__] I wasn't scared to look
everybody hell no I wanted to look at
fools I wanted to this is a home crowd
in there like yeah it was our [__]
fans and Friends it was way yeah it
wasn't a cold crowd at all no it was
awesome
all right so this before we can sleep on
the ground basically Frank gallery
right though the question you're like uh
just go to sleep you're gonna sleep two
hours and then we talked about [__]
video games and [__] forever
hey France City all right I like it that
concludes where you're at that's over
under done with where are you at oh that
was supposed to be a Grizzle that wasn't
it myself
so you don't have your headphones you
don't like to participate in our games
he had a super six sound lined up and it
wasn't that one scared the [__] out of
me it happens it happens sometimes it
happens from time to time gunshots might
go off but you know it's your time time
to go don't duck [__] god it's your
time if that's your time
I've dodged my [__] [__] yeah some
bullets in my whole [__] [__] the
mass Jim Carrey wow that's him I mean
[__]
you had a mask one loaded up
pull the gym carry the mask sound out I
wish you had headphones on and you
weren't too cool to put headphones on no
I'm saying I don't need them I can hear
what other producers any of that stuff
that's the Jim Carrey while changing the
camera
while talking about Jim Carrey let's
just say [__] Crush that right now oh
God damn it damn it
to me praise you
it's okay
you don't know what's going on don't you
just left out like these ones are
[__] weird I know
you want a fake dude he'll laugh when he
watches it back you want a fake news
why did it do I'll hit the crease I was
like what just slide across the [__]
these things are like it's
so crisp and fresh God fresh crisp boom
boom boom
look at OG yeah okay well thank you you
guys let me see what I'm saying
um ready hit that right here shot at the
hash house it's an empty box you want to
hit the pen
oh I love [__] with this oh we got
the glue on Deck yeah that gorilla goes
strong
look at all G puffing it puffing it not
even really hit oh there we go there you
go if Dana White can make a slap league
and we go stop Oh I thought you were
gonna say something no no that's just
ironic that he got his own Slatterly
going see see
guys let's get out of here real quick
for everyone watching I really hope I
get this real quick I am
hold on hold on
the leg call me
behind the back
hey yo hey yo yo hey yo pretty close it
broke mid-air you saw it but no
splitting two pieces damn it
it's okay hey how you feeling damn you
ripped that blueberry I could smell it
right see those little five milligrams
then do nothing
brought out his [__] host yeah it
brought out your inner intellectual
no it was good this is the best episode
we've done so far with you man you
didn't get all clammed up you didn't
text me dad man like you can usually ask
me different questions
now this was a good one We're Not Gonna
even mention your Instagram because you
don't do anything
um OG has no social media presence if
you guys want to go see OG just go look
at old videos I've done if you want to
follow me I'll just show you just
[__] nothing he's at shark turds on
Instagram
like I said but I just posted my story
that's it I know but boom [__] get
pictures now they do that
reported right away it's like [__] I
don't even want to [__] uh like I
said right now I got pictures that are
still there next week I'll get reported
for a picture that's been there for
[__] two years ago and [__] dude
YouTube Just age restricted our Ryan
sickler episode episode [__] two I
already appealed it Andy appealed and
the first Josh Wolf one the [__] it took
years and years
out of here boom boom boom and the Brian
counten episode age restricted
yeah a bunch of our comedian episodes
years old and [__] yeah two years old
like I said somebody just actually takes
the time and Bam and but not with the
stories
with the stories that some [__] yeah you
could because you know what my last uh
one of my other accounts the one I had
first that one guy [__] deleted just
[__] for me posting a [__] Raider
logo damn really bro that's all I
[__] post this I'll tell you the next
day gone sorry wasn't that but maybe it
wasn't that I you know what maybe it
wasn't but it was you call that guy a
[__] no I think it was that you know I
think they commented on the world star
too oh you probably said something super
hateful and I think I got like 1900
likes or yeah
what I said agreed with him or whatever
they're called and I think it might that
was a that was like a day before that I
remember that was like on a Friday I did
that and then by by Sunday night after
the Raider game was just bam gone God
damn like [__] all you did was post a
Raider logo with a hateful cat somebody
could DM you some actual horrible [__]
and then you report it to Instagram and
they don't do nothing about it no no
because the guy who sees it he just
[__] laughs at it says [__] them yeah
yeah big deal boom boom boom well if you
want to go look at a stagnant ass page
that does not post [__] go follow OG's
Instagram [__] you'll see some [__] it's
floating right here what is it real [__]
76 what is it
uh OG Chris 76 underscore
all right if you like that shot of the
east L.A sign yeah if you like that same
story of him Easton Lakes Wine plinking
maybe a grow with a boomerang
um if you go follow OG because he
doesn't want to do anything else for us
now you know what why don't make it you
guys tell me what you guys want to post
if I get so much
we want Fitness push-ups
we want Joey Diaz motivational morning
[__] we want you coming out hey weasel
tits wake up [__] hitting burpees
exactly yes whatever you want to do in
good life [__] it oh that's what we want
and then once you start break dancing
again yeah bro you'd blow the phone you
would [__] blow up come on your
cousin [__] dog face is got arrested
for some pot too it was for wheat I have
no idea that's that that's some [__]
um so yeah all right fun episode man
it's one of the last episode it was the
last episode you'll ever do oh [__] move
into the new studio soon whoa that's it
that's weird we've had three different
versions I'm not even nervous anymore
after that Ted Talk oh yeah nothing
nothing matters anymore that [__] was
the most nervous [__] of all time
anything [__] sick Oprah's ass across
the street what's up Oprah remember when
you used to [__] uh interview clan
members when you first started yeah no
he didn't forget you know I'm standing
now no she's tight though she's hella
sick actually but don't be forget we
didn't forget that's like I remember
somebody commented I post like 40 pack
one time on Instagram when I first
started and me laying in like a 40 pack
like a chair
and somebody wrote one day when you're
in your 40s or 50s you're gonna really
regret this photo and I went
unless I'm a politician I don't think it
matters and then I thought
I'm going to remember this comment
forever I did I don't regret it why the
[__] would I just picture it's a [__]
billboard [__] give a [__] I was making
high on it right I still remembered it
yeah we got you where you're at yeah it
wasn't for all those packs I don't know
I just thought it was weird like you're
gonna regret this one day I'm like wrong
it's not an only fans picture of my
Shark butthole like it's Jesus Christ
it's just so weird
yeah I keep thinking it's for dude
dookie and you know [__] gems
that'd be sick look at this phone's not
even listening he's completely gone
space the [__] out
they did the shark eat you [__] who
knows you know it was those who knows
what the [__] dude
yeah [__] I don't know where they
[__] 50 milligrams
each of those they're 50. really [__]
that damn they're strong all right
thanks for being here man appreciate it
did a good job this time to get a good
job I already know that evil does a good
job dad you just call me that in front
of everybody that was right here you
called me that that was weird you know
Daddy I do good did you hear that hey
all about the pauses and the commas
where you place them is how you worded
that everybody heard it my son you heard
that his son's at home
everybody driving I'm sorry the dead
silence is I'm just staring at OG
because he's like so what do you want me
to say something
here or you just hit the pen again
it's okay
then [__] [__] let's do it damn
that's what happened huh I noticed you
started like go out of nowhere in my
[__] smile [__] went up [__] it I
just started listening
I just started listening to you guys
that's exactly what happened thank you
man thank you for being here thank you
for coming here on such short notice and
uh real quick yesterday we asked oh gee
can we do 12 30 he goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah what about like two o'clock just 12
30 is good yeah 12 32 2 o'clock what the
[__] is it 12 30 or two then he text me
at two in the morning hey what about 12
30.
yeah 12 30 is fine I called him at 11
50. he's like what's up man no I was
doing something so
you wanna do later
oh yeah I forgot to text you that [__]
like nah that's cool what about like
three o'clock perfect I called him back
yeah three o'clock yeah four o'clocks
man three four o'clocks great like how
about six
perfect we got here at seven o'clock
called him at 6 10. I looked outside
he's like he should be pulled up I
called him he has no [__] shirt on
walking through his house yeah I said
yeah you said six o'clock I'm like at 6
10. yeah I know
I'm leaving my house in three minutes he
got here at seven he lives 15 minutes
away no matter what you left 40 minutes
later I'm gonna [__] throw this
against the wall
I just did the math in my head I think I
just I just woke up too I dude you were
just sleeping bag what's happening
oh boy last night I [__] sold we got
[__] um Justin [__] pulls up we'll
pull up to the [__] bottle we're up
there on top and you know
drinks there they don't sound [__]
[__] there bro [__] old ass theater
oh my gosh you know what I'm wearing a
liquor store [__] homeboy goes to the
liquor store comes back with a [__]
bottle of [__] Chinese whiskey yeah
yeah some Chinese whiskey you don't have
something like Chinese [__] said
whiskey some [__]
and I was just like what I was like [__]
oh you could have bought anything else
but [__] whiskey whiskey [__] just
with me it I haven't drank whiskey in
about I want to say
eight years hmm you know what I mean
because last time I drank Your Whiskey
was on a Christmas Day and I [__] up
Christmas you did yeah eight years ago
yeah at your own house you [__] up
Christmas yeah
what'd you do what you do what you do
tell me real quick before you get here
come on uh I want to hear this well
[__] um
just
whoa just say it blacked out I'm [__]
blacked out everybody to [__] uh I
think it was okay so it started with I
sold it I saw this real quickly so I
sold a truck to one of my cousins and um
her to her husband you know he which he
wasn't my he just found family by her
you know because he's with my cousin so
[__]
I saw my truck that I got for a hundred
bucks literally a hundred how on Earth
do you even get that weight of metal and
rubber for a hundred dollars it was just
one of my cousins said hey I have this
truck in my [__] in my driveway if
you [__] want it give me a hundred
bucks and get it the [__] out of here
bro is inflation that bad so no no I'm
telling you this is back there this was
nothing this was still like about this
was like tomorrow
yeah so you know it's like I went to his
Pad my cousin not knowing that all he
needed was a battery
I took the truck I'm like yeah I'll take
it take the truck win a [__] AutoZone
[__] bought a battery put it in there
truck started like nothing put gas in it
the truck was [__] running fine I had
a cousin that [__] was walking in the
foot with her with her boyfriend they
had just had a kid and [__] so [__]
he was just you know they were just
walking and like [__] it I told him you
know what bro you want the truck [__]
give me 200 eh just give me 100 bucks
for my battery when I paid whatever my
time give me 200 bucks give me 200 bucks
dude sold the truck [__] the next day
it helps [__] pissed and then [__]
you know we're [__] um what a [__]
[__] he [__] you know right there
[__] next next day I see him or I think
it was Christmas and that's when we run
into each other
and so they told me about what kind of
[__] was that bro like I could have
[__] sold that truck for [__] two
thousand dollars but you know I said
I've seen you guys walking I give you a
truck to go selling me and then this
pool [__] tells me oh and he calls me
the uh you know he uses the n word you
know what yeah
what story took the [__] left and
then a right fast as [__]
sorry continue continue so anyways he
calls me he calls me and he says [__]
you know yeah and I'm like what the [__]
I was like bro what the [__] was that
kind of answer bro when I'm asking you
about that
you know this was all like you know
these guys are I'm like what boom you
know what I mean [__] this and we
[__] and next to you know thank you
for giving Marty something to bleep out
but keep going
continue oh please got [__] up
yeah how did that ruin Christmas that
didn't ruin Christmas he ruined
Christmas because after that bro I mean
he did that that's his fault you
couldn't [__] yeah just like I was
just uncontrollable
um it was just [__] I got his ass
after they took me to the side I already
had I just drank like [__] I want to
say I want to say drank the whole bottle
of bouquets
[__] drank that whole [__] and
[__] [__] that dude up yeah you know
what I mean and then he got there and
then I was like whoa bro what [__]
kind of [__] was that bro what the [__]
yeah we're gonna keep going there's more
bleep [__] but yeah anyways but yeah
yeah and [__] and he said like all
right when he said he like backed his
head up like yeah
you know but he said you know what the
animal I was like what what the [__] bro
what kind of [__] was that bro like you
didn't even [__] give me an
explanation so bam I might just hit this
one man I think any word he said he's
deserved to get punched in the face your
mom's the best still [__] soccer yeah
you know so after that he just started a
big old commotion you know [__]
bromelino we started fighting and [__]
did you win and um why wasn't even it
just we had too many family members
involved everybody's in the Bible all
the kids are there and [__] I mean it
was like Christmas time hey bro so now
you ruined I get why you ruined
Christmas okay Christmas Day everyone's
there you know everything just [__]
[__] chaos you know what I'm trying
to raise my kids Christmas was done and
[__] I knocked over [__] over her
[__] the Grinch that green hat look
at him
no actually you know what I don't
remember all that you know I blacked out
that's that that was the time when I had
never had drinking whiskey before that's
why that's why we're back to Whiskey wow
and [__] yeah and and this is this is
why I said I never [__] with whiskey
no more till [__] yesterday damn your
Edibles can make this fall wait you're
[__] talking about the whole thing
from the subject this one went to TED
talks yeah you know what man I'm gonna
[__] talk like that damn this was all
[__] talking Professor [__]
[__]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's all right it's all right uh that's
[__] funny you know what I mean and
[__] so [__] was keeping yeah
give me whiskey and I was [__] it
just it got me [__] pretty lit yo all
I'm gonna take away from this
full drinks teas
he's Becky he does crystals not Crystal
he has crystals he's different slides
down the uh strip he's he belly slides
down the strip he has the octopus that
means something
and what was the last thing we just
talked about
oh he can't handle his liquor I gets me
wild whiskey gets me
so everything is here he's like I've
heard other people say these things in
different like tones and they were all
like these white girls I knew like oh I
have a certain friends no vodka oh you
want to fight
you can't [__] I don't know what it is
it that alcohol makes me buy like wow
well I mean that's it I think there's a
different type with vodka tequila and
[__] it's all the same tonight I mean
I get I don't understand it's just
because it doesn't affect me that way so
I'm like why would it do that bring out
violence yeah
it brings out a whole different a whole
different character out of you yeah I'm
saying some people say like I can't
drink that or fight people I can't drink
this I'll [__] argue with my
girlfriend or oh I'll be a dick on that
on a specific specific drink yeah I know
a lot of people like they call whiskey
oh I'll fight this for like a whiskey
I'll [__] mirror on Christmas [__]
like that I call April uh like
confrontational Connie that's her Alter
Ego she slips into it oh
okay with people random people she wants
to talk to everybody but she'll also
like be very quick to [__] slide that
energy into a [__] argument and slide
that into [__] stop outside
no to a stop-out session yo people you
know what's scary being a girl
and and meeting people like April that
you don't know she looks so nice all
done up like that girl stomped that girl
out in the [__] Street pull her
[__] hair and walked away that's
scary as [__] because you see a dude
like ho ho ho I don't want to fight that
[__] you see it
not all the time but you could sense it
like with girls you're like oh no she
tied her hair it's a mom oh she took she
has cauliflower ears oh [__] she gonna
beat the [__] out of me like you don't
know what's gonna happen with girls
because that doesn't happen often yeah
that's true that's scary point it's the
next time
Eddie Murphy's my co-host besides party
he's gonna come out and give his whole
speech for bra or Delirious I mean
so I'm about to do this whole [__]
African I need to go to Africa and find
a wife remember that uh
Eddie
yo yo you can cancel for some [__] like
that today I don't give a [__] it's
still funny as hell sorry Eddie Murphy
season three Eddie Murphy for Real come
sit down after this Ted talk [__] I
think I can sit down still will sassa
scares me yeah it's still hard to keep
up with chords like that yeah I don't
know if I can even like so
um well how do you wake up what do you
how do you sleep like no matter what you
say he's gonna shift it back
yeah so there's a few people that do
that so anyway we have to end this
episode OG doesn't post at all uh we'll
just check everything out appreciate you
guys so much uh this is the first filmed
episode of the year
mm-hmm yep thanks for being here guys we
got a couple big guests coming in we're
back at it we're filming [__] three
episodes in four days and we got a dopa
Zola videos multiple ones and longer the
story time of all time coming up hour
and a half
got a [__] hour and a half story time
oh it's a full movie Lake boo Lake movie
yeah
um all right thanks for being here man
you want to go to my house and get
higher
let's go all right let's go yeah you
don't have a car so you have to come
with me your wife is at my house with
Rosie all right guys thank you so much
for being here this has been the dope as
usual podcast this is my co-host Marty
O'Neal this is OG thank you so much for
being here thank you everyone thank you
for Jay and Rocco oh and Tony Tony
studio audience in studio Walkers
they're silent I didn't even get over
there they're the best ones hey ever
thank you guys so much for being this is
the dope as usual podcast we're here and
we talked about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between have a dope ass day I am so high
and just brain dead that Ted Talk it was
great it went great but wow my brains
I almost couldn't say eligibility
remember that that was crazy
good episode
[Music]